[موسيقى]
الموسيقى في سلطنه عمان جزء اصيل في شخصيه
الانسان العماني طاهره جمال من اشهر عازفي
اله الكمان في السلطنه حيث بدات التعلم
على هذه الاله منذ نعومه اظافرها
بدايه الموسيقى وانا بالعمر 11 سنه
الوالد اعرض لي اني انا اقدم في
الفرقه السلطانيه
وكان هناك يعني يحتاجوا فرقه خاصه نسائيه
وف انا وخواتي قدمنا فيه هذا الفرقه
والحمد لله جهه الاختيار فيني انا وايضا
خوات عندي الاثنين
[موسيقى]
طاهره عضوه في فرقه دار الاوبرا السلطانيه
وشاركت في العديد من المحافل الدوليه
في مشاركات كم شركه في افتتاحيه الملعب
المونديالي في قطر 2017
وايضا في مشاركه مع الفنان جهاد عقل
العازف الكمال العالمي في دار الاوبرا
السلطانيه
[موسيقى]
رائد الفارسي الذي فقد بصره لكن بصيرته
الفنيه اثرت المشهد الموسيقي في سلطنه
عمان
بدات منذ الطفوله المبكره باستخدام
الهالات عرفت
النواه الموسيقيه بطريقه طبعا برايل لتعلم
بها المكفوفين
ولقاعات والمقامات الموسيقيه كل هذا
ساعدني في صقر الموهبه الموسيقيه بعد ذلك
[موسيقى]
عبد الرحمن العصيمي من مسقط العربيه